sorry
gets a bit emotionally but I talk about
it now one of the most powerful films I
think we ever made was the film we made
in the Congo it was about the
interracial violence between the Hutus
and the Tutsis that had followed over
from Rwanda into the eastern part of the
Democratic Republic of Congo what people
were doing in these these militias these
guerrillas out in the jungle they were
going into other villages with the
opposing tribe they killed the men then
they would hack the women's arms off at
the elbow while they was still alive
they would gang rape them making the
younger soldiers go first then they
would heats up sticks and insert them
into the women they'd use bayonets on
the end of the ak-47 to basically rip
them apart and then once they'd finished
that heat up a plastic water bottle and
then insert it into the woman so that
when she was pregnant she would explode
dr. McCrae guy runs the Panzi Hospital
on Lake kaboom he saves around 2000
women a year his life is continuously
threatened and for me is when the best
men other men
you